there's them [ __ ]
[Music]
and there's dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
what up gq this is vic mensa and these
are my essentials
so you pretty much always see me in a 93
punx jacket
93 punks is my label we mainly like
repurpose
vintage leathers denims this jacket i'm
wearing right here is 93 punks
it has real story not only did these
articles of clothing have a full
lifetime before me
but like now they have their own life
with me like this jacket still has
blood stains on it from like a crazy
fight
i got into this real sex drugs in rock
and roll
this is one of my favorite joints though
not for sale
i have fun making my own clothes it's
like i get to express the
things that i want to see represented
aesthetically
i also don't ever like wearing what
other people wear you know because if
somebody else got it on at the same
place as me it's like i i might have to
leave you know
and go change i'm too forward to be on
the same
playing field my next essential is this
1982
presidential 18 carat rolex rap is such
a show
boat gaudy arena the biggest chain with
the most diamonds i'm not into bust down
rolexes i just think it looks tacky i
always wanted to just have like a
classic rolex you know something your
grandfather would have
something you'll pass down to your
children you know what i'm saying and i
also don't wear diamonds being african
myself being ghanaian there's so much
conflict behind diamonds and
you have to be very dedicated in
particular to make sure
that the diamonds you're getting are not
born in conflict
and nobody's doing that i'm sure that a
lot of guys walking around
coveting conflict diamonds right now and
i'm not judging them for that but it's
just not for me
so no bust down big face rolly for me no
diamonds
so this is the giuseppe chelsea boot
with the cuban heel
this hill is like a it's an alligator
the metal work detailing on
on the back i had a chance meeting with
giuseppe
in new york city i saw some boots he was
making for women
and i was like man you know that would
be amazing
for a man you know sure enough he was
like give me three weeks
and it showed up at my door and i was
like whoa you know
so shout out to giuseppe for show
another essential of mine
is these white gold teeth courtesy of my
boy big o
you know i was inspired by a couple
things with these teeth first of all
i wanted to look like a guatemalan
street urchin or street merchant
either one i think i pulled it off but i
also was inspired by
the joker the joker's teeth are crazy so
i got this love
this jagged thing from over there and i
was inspired by
johnny depp i'm not feeling him so much
anymore the evidence seems to be
overwhelming that
he's a piece of [ __ ] but his silver
teeth are cool so i took
the two bottom ones you know from him so
i kind of got that pirate street
merchant vibe
going on yeah the same vicious glasses
this is another recent essential of mine
i got them from a
vintage store named please and thank you
store and uh
it's been brought to my attention that
yg also wears
small glasses but this is a completely
me move
shout out to the man yg400 yeah i mean
but these are
vicious joints you know i mean i put
them on look like a creek
real quick switch out then i get on real
creep mode
whatever i do you can't hold me too
accountable because i was wearing these
glasses you knew i was a weirdo
the tc helicon man this is a real
essential of my
life it's what i use to write it's what
i'm most natural with
it's a songwriting tool basically it's
like effects
for your voice delay and reverb and
harmonizer effects
auto-tune and i did a song the other day
and my homegirl was like yeah i don't
like it because i don't like auto-tune
and i'm just like i'm sorry then i'm
sorry for you
you know because auto-tune is amazingly
fun you know i mean
it's like we should be able to use
technology and move forward
create new sounds and new ideas without
being held back by our commitment to the
past you know i'm always trying to think
about
what's after what's next recently i
started
writing down music on paper again i've
been carrying around this little
notebook
shout out to sweet green [ __ ] with them
but you know it's just like
the little things that i think about
empathy is the poor man's cocaine i'll
cut the smile off your face
mostly very depressing writings this is
like all the random papers that i've
been
writing on recently sometimes it's songs
sometimes it's just like stream of
consciousness
like depression but i guess that's
that's my way of [ __ ] expressing it
you know what i'm saying because i've
been going through a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of depression anxiety suicidal
ideation all the dark stuff
it helps me out to just fully express it
you know to just put it on paper putting
things on paper
is kind of like immortalizing them
when i write things down in the phone it
just gets jumbled up with instagram and
twitter and all these fleeting
temporary things these notebooks still
have
things i wrote in them when i was 15
years old
you know what i'm saying i had a brick
phone at that point in time with the
snake 2 on it if i had wrote it down in
my nokia
it wouldn't still be around you know but
i wrote it on paper so it's still here
10 years later i write on paper so that
it can last
[Music]
motorcycle helmet riding a motorcycle
2018
is probably the best decision i made
it's like the most fun that i've had
and it's fun on a daily basis this
helmet was given to me
by a member of the good charlotte camp
i'm doing a punk project
it's really like punk music over like
trap beats rap beats
so we were in with with joel madden
who's a super cool guy
i was talking about how i needed a
better helmet something that had some
ventilation in it and his homies just
went into this back room
pulled out the helmet and some gloves
and just gave him to me
because i guess they used to ride bikes
but their wives won't let them ride
bikes anymore
i don't have a wife or anybody that can
really tell me what to do luckily
so they gave me this helmet one thing i
really like about this helmet and it
came with this
is the zoo york sticker on the back
which is legendary
the zoo york mixtapes are actually what
got me into rap music i only liked rock
and roll
before i heard step into a world
krs one on this zoo york
like vhs tape and that was the first rap
song i liked so shout out to zoo york
and
rest in peace harold hunter legends
never die
yeah i've been wearing these dog tags
recently in case i get
shot and killed by the police that i can
be identified
[Music]
yeah you know i feel a little bit bad
about promoting cigarette smoking
but i guess if you're gonna smoke you
might as well smoke american spirits
right because it's like a little bit
more healthy it's probably still [ __ ]
up i'm promoting it to the kids
but you know whatever i'm not i'm not
really a role model
i'mma keep it a stack with you bro i
don't know the difference sometimes i
get the yellow sometimes i get the light
blues
i don't know which is which i'm sure one
of them's supposed to be like the light
cigarette but i have this special [ __ ]
that i do i put
a drop of peppermint oil on the filter
of each cigarette
and it's like a whole foods newport it's
like like a vegan newport
it's crazy don't smoke cigarettes kids
it's late for me
it's a little bit late for me but for
you if you haven't started
don't do it because you think it's cool
because i'm cool because i'm not
cool and neither are cigarettes
i've been wearing the [ __ ] out of these
man it's my last essential
is these 93 punks carhartt pants there's
a lot of detailing on here you know what
i'm saying
destroy fascism the dead kennedys jump
off
straight 93's alien sex fan agnostic
front black flag black flag is another
one of my favorite favorite bands all
the patches are stitched on with dental
floss
real authentic fashion and i've just
been wearing these a lot recently like
i often just like crash on the couch
wearing all my clothes
yeah so this is from the upcoming 93
punks line be on the lookout
fashion and music and these are just
limbs to my soul to my to my mind my
spirit the essentials are
the pieces that make that puzzle whole
thank you gq
these are my essentials please don't try
and steal the sauce don't try this at
home it's very risky and very dangerous
peace
[Music]